ظاهره غير المرئيه ربما كان يعني فيها
كريمي الافتراضيه يقابلها واقع يعيشوا
الافغانيون كل يوم يستغله التنظيم الفجوه
بين طالبان والافغان المتفاقمه بالفقر
البطاله والسياسات المخيبه لامال الشعب
قدرته داعش خرسان دلالاتها تتجاوز عدد
الهجمات المنفذه في افغانستان وهي بالمئات
نتحدث عن اكثر من 300 هجمه منذ الحركه
للسلطه في اغسطس 2021
عمليات تمتا في اكثر الاماكن المحصنه
امنيا قرب مقر وزاره الخارجيه وفي الفندق
الذي كان يرتده الصينيون والاكثر شهره
مشاهدينا على الاطلاق الهجمه التي وقعت في
مطار كابل قتل على اثر العمليه فيه ثلاثه
عشر من مشاهده البحريه الامريكيه اهداف
صعبه تتجاوز مرحله استهدافي اقليه الهزاره
وحتى اماكن العباده ام حين نتحدث عن العدد
فيدق ان قوس الخطر في ارض النشاه في سوريا
فمنذ بدايه العام اي في الاسبوعين الاوائل
من 2023 نفذ داعش هجوما كل يوم وفي سوريا
ايضا السجون قنبله موقوته تحوي جيشا
محتجزا يؤرق واشنطن والغرب ويضعهما في
معادله معقده مع قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
حارسه السجون خاصه بعد عمليه داعش في سجن
جويران او في سجن الصناعه في الحسكه قبل
عام من اليوم قتل خلالها اكثر من 100 عنصر
من قصد
بحسب الجنرال مايكل لاريك كورولا قائد
القياده المركزيه الامريكيه هناك
10,000 من قاده ومقاتلي داعش مسجونين في
سوريا وضعفهم في العراق وهناك جيل قادم
محتمل من التنظيم في مخيم الهول قوامه
25,000 طفل خطرنا اديهم على المدى البعيد
تؤجل واشنطن التعامل معه ربما كي لا نقلته
لكن هناك ما هو خارج عن السيطره حتى لو
ارادت الطعاطي معه السلاح
المنفلت من الحرب التي ينغمس فيها الغرب
باسلحه حتى نفذ مخزون معظم دولها
الاستراتي بعد اخر لدعوه التنظيم لانصاره
في امر الماضي لاستغلال الانغماس الغرب في
الحرب الاوكرانيه الاسلحه
تسهل السوق السوداء الاوكرانيه المفتوحه
الامر عبرها تباع صواريخ جافل وستنجر التي
ورددها الغرب الاكياف الكلام